one of the things that sets eSports
apart is that it's truly global still
pro players are more common in some
places than others a long wait country
I'm coming from the country that made P
what I am today so I want to give
something back it's raining in here come
the parties as well god he just put one
down if I second you better believe he
can not another Ladislav guardian Kovac
managed to make his way into the elite
of counterstrikes competitive community
from a small European country mostly
unknown in the scene and he did it
through his sheer dedication to the game
quickly falling apart here for not me
getting a bit scary but that Guardian is
I'm gonna say about that takes out the
kill on a barge
but despite playing with some of the
best players the game has ever seen and
holding his own as one of the most
Brousseau tile and effective offers ever
[Applause]
there is still something guardian has
yet to do win a major born in 1991
Guardian grew up in Slovakia at age 10
his brothers copy of Counter Strike
found its way into the home and it was
instantly something that Guardian
understood in 2001 it was old 1.3 and
the old estate map and when I brother
brother he is home and I used I started
playing the game 1 verse 10 the hardest
books and I felt like I can shoot I can
do everything I want over the next eight
years Guardian would continue to play
1.6 but also tried counter-strike source
all the while he was still living in
Slovakia and playing with domestic teams
there he was during this time that
Guardian picked up the AWP and if it
wasn't for the fact that he was playing
in a smaller region he may not have
become an offer at all
I began just because we our city didn't
tell a solid sniper that could actually
help us so that's that the there's a
story behind it and I'm happy it
happened that way during this period his
first roster that competed at an
international LAN was reason gaming a
combined Czech and Slovak roster his
first CS source LAN event was land 79 a
reoccurring French tournament where some
thought the team was cheating but
Guardian just under a year into his time
with the game was still playing like it
was one point
you know coming from 1.6 you just want
to play the game the same way like you
want to wallbang and stuff like this so
Darian made the jump to see us go after
it became clear that the title would be
embraced by the competitive community
even if their initial reception was less
than cordial the other three like lucky
Ted said all three of them weren't
really like convinced that she's gonna
be big and I don't think any all three
the players didn't like the game he
still didn't love the game and even
considered switching away from the off
given the changes to the weapon then I
mean my hated the game completely I
don't know why I didn't like it too much
of trash on the map like chickens and
other stuff despite eventually coming
around to the game Guardian spent his
early career in global Offensive playing
on mostly regional teams including the
Czech Slovakian mixed team my DGP now
working a job at hewlett-packard
Guardian had to find time for the game
even bringing his PC to work during a
night shift so that he could play a
qualifier for the first I am Katowice
tournament is wasted but my reviewin
like we had a team of five people like
shift and my guys were very nice and
they knew I'm playing CS competitively
they shift captain told me that yeah
Milo - so they didn't tell anyone
Guardians first big break outside his
region would come with virtus Pro in
June 2013 at the time vp was a russian
and ukrainian mixed team and Guardian
didn't speak any Russian he was forced
to learn as he went and credits Fox with
helping him a month after guardians
edition angel and doja left for Astana
dragons Guardian was on the move again
but had made enough of an impact outside
his home region to get noticed he was
chosen as the 10th best player of 2013
by hltv org Guardians offing style was
versatile focused around his ability to
flick with the AWP whether he was
holding an angle defensively
aggressive every time I will monitor by
all piped up even if I own or more
another hallmark of his play is his
uncanny ability to clutch even in
terrible situations right won't be one
he's running the coke to the absolutely
after playing on a mixed team with
Edward who had also been part of Astana
dragons Guardian was invited to join
natus vincere Guardian had spent a long
time in his home region and had only a
short live stint with VP but Navi would
end up being his home for years to come
also on the roster was Zeus the team's
in-game leader renowned for his slow and
methodical approach to the game and see
him they didn't see him when he came
through he gets to sprayed on an oath
read that strategy gave Guardian plenty
of time to find picks while the team
played around him he was pretty good at
reading go puns and he had the balls to
to call tactic 50 seconds left
the team's major debut was at ESL major
series 1 Katowice but they finished 13th
16th after a full month of boot camp but
an immediate opportunity to rebound
presented itself fnatic had declined
their spot in starladder series 9 based
on the ongoing crisis in ukraine but the
tournament would be huge for the
resurgence of the na'vi squad they
didn't drop a single map as the team
defeated n IP twice and tightened it was
exactly the sort of win that the new
roster needed suddenly they were on the
map and Guardian style broke into the
mainstream
it feels always kind of special because
it was my first bigger youant I think
back then it was like 100 K or 50k so
yeah it feels special and still I feel
like you know the CIS fans and
everything like that they stay behind me
and cheer for me so yeah in the run-up
to the next 2014 major in Cologne
they look
they could do real damage though Zeus
with the season gets two kills big frags
there and Navi they're on the brink of
turning it around in the second round of
this first half but after getting out of
groups as the second seed they ran
directly into fnatic that series
featured furious action but Navi went
out in a narrow 1614 on nuke Natick go
through after a hard-fought battle all
three backs going to No although Navi
were firmly in the conversation as a
contender it was over three months until
they got another shot at a valve major I
don't know it was always close matchup
like even in : we lost 2-1 to fnatic
1614 last map so we always miss tons of
something so I hope it will be known
this time and we go so but the results
na'vi were eliminated in the semi-finals
by eventual winners ldlc
plc there in the grand finals of
dreamhack winter 2014 they beat Navi in
the semis the next few months were quiet
for the team in terms of competition
until the next major in March 2015 at
ESL one Katowice after a gain working
their way out of groups the team fell to
the same French players they did in
Cologne this time representing team
envyus I'm glad we got to see the dust
to the Cana of Navi was inspirational
and Guardian such a key figure Guardian
was the only member of Navi to be
positive overall for the series and the
team went out in the quarterfinals they
had shown some positive potential but so
far had only broken the top four at a
major once outside of Valve majors the
team had only seen significant success
at the most recent three starladder
events and at dreamhack summer after the
tournament
starix stepped down from the team to
become a coach analyst and a manager
flamie joined as a stand-in before
becoming a permanent member
while Guardian had often been relied
upon to take a starring role
flamie added firepower to the team they
gave him one
to work with despite their inconsistent
results Guardian was becoming a hallmark
name synonymous with excellence with the
our crazy idea past the shop Guardian it
actually works he along with French
opera Kenny s were the two names on the
tip of everyone's tongue when asked
about the game's best snipers but the
two had very different approaches to the
game go begging Kenny's gonna go ahead
and peek at a second but there was not a
doubt he's always being like about the
toughest best really the top three best
helpers in the world it like me the
middle of 2015
again some mixed results Navi took ESL
pro league 1 and star series 13 from
both of France's best rosters and one
ESWC 2015 though some notable rosters
were not attending and now it's all on
shroud he has 17 seconds and he goes for
the fighting goes down 16 France had its
revenge at ESL one cologne the next
valve major after the group stage he
Navi had to play against envyus in the
quarterfinals Kenny and Guardian facing
off is he gonna try and go huge in
go for that play and make it a three
nothing and build the maps were closed
they lost 2-0
it was another top eight appearance for
Navi where they had not met their own
expectations over the next few months
they managed top four appearances at a
bevy of events but didn't win any still
their consistency suggested cluj-napoca
2015 the upcoming valve major might be
their best chance yet to take it all God
in covering from pan
[Music]
Guardian is gonna get the frag that wins
the map even in the early stages of this
tournament envy and Kenny was there to
threaten Navi in the same group Navi
lost their match against the French side
but still made it out of groups as the
second seed the path to the grand finals
was not easy luminosity gaming the best
Brazilian team were increasingly showing
they were topped to your competitors and
ninjas in pyjamas stood in the way in
the semi-finals but once they had fought
all the way to the grand finals it was
team envyus again standing in their way
and this is just a legendary lineup
against another legendary line of two
legendary lines going at it the two
legendary offers going at it and today
we'll see one of those offers we've
never won a major before take the title
now these dominance on their map pick of
train was immediately challenged by NV
and the French side took it 1614
including a heartbreak in 1v2 by happy
he's there for the clutch said it's
gonna be Guardian now 1v2 to keep his
team in this take over overtime Navi now
had to somehow win on cobble a map they
for all intents and purposes didn't play
they couldn't push it to a third map
[Applause]
[Music]
a 16-5 stomp saw a guardian get the
closest he had ever been to a
championship and then fall short I'll
surely to her still to lose a final like
that because next time was Kabul and we
never practice Kabul before this was the
major Guardian could have won it just
you know hurts how when you see how you
lose the the final so of course if you
are professional player you think about
it and you know the memories from it so
yeah as the number showed he wasn't the
problem
Guardian was +12 across both maps better
than any other player in the server
besides Kenny he was also selected as
the tournament MVP so do this Guardian
taking down happy gonna go for the next
that's the bomb as the dust settled from
Cluj the team had an incredible rebound
performance at IEM San Jose though the
event was an invitational on spaces like
these was the first time that people
like a theme like either playing at the
end the team was now consistently making
finals and a major win seemed possible
oh the cap like peekaboo ligardi eyebrow
in just over two months in early 2016
the team raked in over one hundred and
fifty thousand dollars in prize money at
counter Pitt League season 2 finals
Guardian destroyed the competition
hosting unbelievable stats in the grand
final against Astralis so when MLG major
championship Columbus rolled around
na'vi were a game in the discussion as
one of the favorites but already the
odds were stacked against Guardian i
think angel was there for a long long
like for a month before like okay these
are cons repeat i mean i never realized
that that it could be bad like sometimes
at painting the race but I always
thought it some kind of exhaustion like
I got exhausted in my arm or something
and then I used to play a lot to see us
by then like the injury had been ongoing
but Guardian ignored the problem
thinking it was just normal wear and
tear though the team managed to top
their group and defeat n IP and Astralis
without dropping a map the injury had
flared up by the grand final series
against luminosity Guardian trying to
compensate for his reduced range of
movement in his wrists cranked up the
mouse sensitivity settings but it wasn't
enough
they seem to still be hanging around and
that is sick and Guardian had one of the
worst performances of his career in an
event final story of the tournament so
far you know you've got you've got
Guardian he hasn't shown up someone
needs to get on the phone and ask where
he is the major title again slipped away
in the aftermath despite some early
concerns a doctor did eventually clear
him to play at Dreamhack Malmo the next
big event for the team fans Guardian his
wrists his mouse hand has been injured
he had an inflamed bone or something in
his wrist but apparently he's been
cleared by the doctors he's been cleared
by the Sun to attend the event but it is
you know some strain he's putting some
strain on himself
they took second the next valve major
for Navi was in Cologne
and barely three months from the
previous one in Columbus but instead of
another Finals appearance they went out
5th 8th with a shocking loss to Team
Liquid and their new talents simple by
August 2016
Navi had decided to remove Zeus and add
simple but the change worsened divisions
in the team that had appeared earlier in
the year I think I think like after we
Kings youth I think the change of lineup
didn't happen the way it should happen
though simple was an incredible talent
there were questions about whether the
change was what the team needed while
the space between the last two majors
had been short it would be nearly half a
year before the next in the interim both
Navi and Guardian managed a career
milestone winning a big premier event
with a $250,000 prize pool
at ESL one New York Navi went undefeated
in the swiss group and then defeated
Team Liquid and virtus Pro in the
bracket to take first Guardian overcome
by emotion refused to hide it
I've been with you for a long time we've
known each other forever doesn't need I
know what this means to you can you put
it in words be a fast
thank God the thing is why I was super
emotional was because I've been
dedicated to see his 24/7 ie I chose
CEA's over friends I chose CS over
family over everything and thinking
about like I lost so many finals and
then finally winning one it changed a
lot like you think about it like finally
the dedication show the show that I can
be in tournaments like that so though it
was a huge moment for Guardian and his
team it would be the last big win for
the roster before his departure the wind
hadn't healed the cracks in the
foundation of the team na'vi didn't make
top 4 at either the e league major
atlanta 2017 or pgl major Krakow it's
their only placement of note in the
first half of 2017 is that the
adrenaline Cyber League a CIS region
tournament where they play second among
four teams jet-lagged tired they still
did it
I mean I mean impressive performs from
VP you've got to give it to them
congratulations to the guys after Krakow
both the team and Guardian were faced
with hard decisions about the future of
the roster Navi had been a home for
Guardian for three and
half years and during that time he had
clearly shown his skill as one of the
world's best offers when I get the flick
anyway take you down skadoodle shroud
gets one got him another kill what's
about to come in from the other angle
looking for the shot but it was also
clear that there were other
opportunities elsewhere and the internal
divisions in the team weren't going to
disappear and now he gave me everything
when I came into the team they gave me
the kind of family they asked me to like
to stay but I had some issues that I can
go couldn't accept and they chose
someone else over me so Guardians next
team shot the CS community in August of
2017
he joined faze clan and the team
acquired olofmeister shortly thereafter
they joined rain Kerrigan and Nico to
form a multinational roster that wasn't
hard to call a super team did you ever
see yourself playing on the same team
with olofmeister on top of with Nico and
now with rain all on one team did you
ever imagine that would happen no to be
honest that's something I wouldn't have
imagined the consistency shown by this
roster far outstripped the Navi squad he
had left the other debut at Dreamhack
masters Malmo 2017 was a disappointment
they didn't let that get to them instead
they doubled down on hard work something
that Guardian was very familiar with
point for phase and the first major with
phase SOG Guardian reached yet another
grand final so the vent was net fight
but mess likely I should say what a shot
for Guardian words out of my mouth as he
nails it through the box he is tagged up
smoke on the ball immediately he's got
the kid doesn't elect to hold on to a
game
do for to smoke will do it fades to the
final accordion is an affluent dog at
Boston it was Guardian dominating in the
grand final series against cloud nine
he's got high hopes but it's not broken
down he goes it's Guardian he's the only
man standing between cloud loyal and the
major it's gonna be a double beat the
football every time number thing clouds
I don't do it there's villainous laser
faith that he was the only player
positive on his team in the final the
action was maybe the greatest of any
major fire there's got to be a rotation
Tariq three minutes five minutes to
Guardian buy one get one free and that
keeps great faith clan in this round but
again he wasn't Guardians major to win
Guardian waits patiently as carmine
Sessa push up
[Applause]
Oh
[Applause]
the team's dedication to being the best
means that Guardian believes that phase
will be the last team he plays with
before he retires sooner or later I
think he'll come and face time it'll be
the last thing he's already shown that
he's very much in form and phase remains
a very real threat you will have other
chances to win majors surely but what if
he doesn't well if I don't win one
before the before I retire from company
season I think it will be very sad be
having individual achievements like
being the best player in the world is
something that is least important in in
your career because this is a team game
I don't care if you don't if it's not
the best but you know you care about
team winnings
still whether or not he wins a major
Guardian has been part of many of the
greatest moments in csgo and created
plenty of his own from a small
competitive region to the biggest stages
in counter-strike history Guardians path
to excellence was forged by sheer
perseverance and some of the greatest
opping the game has ever seen thanks for
watching if you want more great content
just like this be sure to hit the
subscribe button